tour de france est course reprend ses
droits coureurs et responsable se
retrouvent en fin de saison pour régler
la crise du dopage
le directeur les deux médecins de tvn
sont en prison jean marie leblanc sera
notre invité l'euthanasie est l'hôpital
de mantes-la-jolie une infirmière mise
en examen pour homicide volontaire elle
est accusée d'avoir aidé à mourir une
trentaine de malades
bernard kouchner secrétaire d'état à la
santé répondre à nos questions élections
au cambodge les anciens khmers rouges de
pol pot qui participent à un reportage
exclusif dans le bastion de l'ex
rébellion
les rolling stones ce soir au stade de
france 85 mille spectateurs pour une
nouvelle page de la légende du célèbre
groupe rock
madame monsieur bonsoir un peu de calme
après la tempête sur le tour de france
l'étape cycliste a presque fait oublier
aujourd'hui les étapes judiciaires
place au sport avait lancé ce matin le
vice président de l'union cycliste
internationale à l'issue d'une réunion
avec les coureurs et leurs directeurs
sportifs
pas de mouvement de grève comme hier
mais une belle course sur 196 km entre
frontignan et carpentras remportée au
sprint par l'italien daniele nardello
ulrich reste en jaune
laurent frédéric bollée après les
tourments et les errements voici le tour
de l'apaisement
ça aurait dû être une étape de
transition mais pour les coureurs
c'était plus que ça presque un nouveau
départ
laurent jalabert est là bien sûr en
champion de france et il ya même son
père
spectateurs où malgré la canicule c'est
comme si l'atmosphère était devenue plus
respirable
du côté des bouches du rhône un groupe
d'hommes n'a pas tardé à s'échapper et
parmi eux il y a même un coureur de chez
pvm
encore un signe que la course a repris
son rythme dans le col de murs seule
vraie difficulté de l'étape
ils ne seront bientôt plus que 6 devant
c'est à ce moment que luc leblanc tente
un formidable baroud d'honneur pour le
français c'est lors de la chevauchée
magnifique dix vingt trente secondes
d'avancé sur le peloton et le maillot
jaune le blanc encourager porté par une
foule nombreuse vols vers le sommet mais
il reste encore 25 km à parcourir et on
se doute que pour le blanc ce sera dur
derrière le peloton s'est en effet mis
en file indienne
cela signifie qu'il ne se laissera pas
faire alors luc leblanc comprend avant
les alpes son effort et inutile seul il
ne peut rien espérer
l'ancien champion du monde se relève
mais un souffle est vraiment passé dans
cette 13e étape
la victoire ne peut plus échapper donc
aux six hommes de tête
il se prépare au sprint mais même là il
faut faire face à toute sorte
d'adversité un papier qui se colle sur
la tête de stéphane heulot
il ne manquait plus que ça pour le
français l'arrivée se juge finalement
dans un mouchoir de poche
c'est l'italien daniele nardello qui
pour sa deuxième participation seulement
dans tour l'emportent d'un millimètre la
photo finish est formel oui la route du
tour qui aujourd'hui a retrouvé une
partie de son sourire
florent gautreau vous êtes sur la route
du tour près de carpentras alors
l'ambiance est elle plus sereine ce soir
dans le peloton
oui l'ambiance est plus sereine de calme
est revenu dans les hôtels des coureurs
comme dans le peloton
et on peut dire que la course a repris
le dessus savait et il ya une manière
très simple de voir si le calme est
revenu
il suffit de se faufiler sur la ligne
d'arrivée au moment de l'arrivée hier
les regards étaient noirs les paroles
étaient plutôt rares et ce soir eh bien
il y avait à nouveau la cohue ont
répondu aux interviews ce qui n'était
pas vraiment le cas hier la plupart des
coureurs en tout cas nous répondait
autant hier on pouvait craindre que le
tour allait définitivement s'arrêter
autant ce soir on voit mal ce qui
pourrait empêcher les coureurs de
rallier paris en fait la seule vraie
conséquence de la réunion de ce matin
dont vous avez parlé dans les titres
c'est que les coureurs ne veulent plus
répondre aux questions concernant les
affaire festina et tvm il des ils ont
décidé de ne répondre qu'aux questions
concernant le sport et le cyclisme alors
le calme est un petit peu revenu les
relations sont plus sereines entre les
suiveurs les coureurs est également la
presse et on peut penser que jusqu'au 2
août au moins date de l'arrivée sur les
champs-elysées et le sport a repris ses
droits
merci florent gautreau vous allez parler
l'atmosphère était plus tendue ce matin
quand coureurs et directeurs sportifs se
sont réunis avec daniel balle le vice
président de l'union cycliste
internationale il n'y a pas de raison
que le tour ne continue pas le tour
n'est pas synonyme de dopage a déclaré
le vice président il a également précisé
qu'il n'était pas question de mettre en
oeuvre des contrôles de santé dans les
conditions de crise actuelle alexandre
kara nathalie gallet après la folle
journée d'hier c'était ce matin le temps
de la discussion directeur sportif et
représentant du peloton se sont
retrouvés autour d'une table pour
rencontre
le président de l'uci union cycliste
internationale à la sortie c'est une
déclaration aux accents oecuméniques
j'ai apporté évidemment le soutien de
l'union cycliste internationale à tous
les coureurs ainsi qu'à leur encadrement
j'aurais rappeler simplement que être
coureur cycliste est un métier exigeant
et qu' ils méritent de notre part et de
la part de tout le monde
beaucoup de respect voire de
l'admiration pas de nouveaux contrôles
sur le tour mais une table ronde à la
fin de saison s'ils ne rajoutons pas
encore d'examen et les coureurs
cyclistes sont déjà l'écho or les plus
contrôlées dans le cadre des contrôles
antidopage et je rappelle qu'il ya en
plus les contrôles sanguins donc le
cyclisme déjà très contrôlé à me feront
pas plus sur les pubs mais en termes de
politique de prévention
nous sommes convenus de nous retrouver
avec les représentants des coureurs et
les représentants des groupes les
médecins dès la fin de la saison
laurent jalabert quand elle lui rappelle
que le malaise n'a pas disparu pour
autant
mais au départ de l'étape c'est toujours
le même les motifs
il faut que le sport reprenne ses droits
on ne sait pas qui l'a gagnée hier dans
le journal ce difficile de colomiers le
vent cordelia banques
continuer le tour oui moi je suis
d'accord pour le continuer ma condition
que l'on retourne au moins à babré
finalement le départ lui s'est déroulée
dans de bonnes conditions
après l'épreuve d'hier la famille
centriste semble avoir resserré les
rangs il reste une semaine aux coureurs
pour prouver que le tour n'est pas
encore fini mais si les cyclistes
roulent la justice elle suit son cours
le directeur sportif et le médecin de
l'équipe néerlandaise tvm ont été mises
en examen et incarcéré hier soir à la
maison d'arrêt de foix ils seront
transférés lundi à reims pour y être
entendu par un juge d'instruction
olivier galzi jean-pierre pasteur
décontraction affichée pour le directeur
sportif de tvm il vient pourtant
d'apprendre qu'il passera la nuit en
prison lui et le médecin de l'équipe ont
été incarcérés hier soir à la maison
d'arrêt deux fois seulement que la
république de rennes sarki ce jour
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
des chefs d'infraction douanière
circulation des trains sur me régulière
le marchandises dangereuses pour la
santé publique et complicité
en tout huit infractions relevées
concernant deux dossiers
tout d'abord celui de la perquisition
avant-hier à l'hôtel des tv m
après avoir fouillé voiture chambre et
poubelles les enquêteurs ont retrouvé
des dopants et des produits masquants
pour contourner les contrôles et puis il
y à l'origine de la faire le premier
dossier remonte en mars dernier deux
mécaniciens de l'équipe tv m étais
arrêté près de reims au volant d'une
voiture chargée 2 p o
un produit dopant
il ya une semaine interrogé à son hôtel
sur cette affaire le directeur sportif
ni est alors les faits nous n'avons rien
à voir dans cette histoire c'était
quelqu'un de votre équipe
ah bon en mars je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui six priem à retrouver la
mémoire tout comme le médecin de
l'équipe
mais une question demeure quel
responsabilité ont-ils dans ce trafic
désormais loin de leur équipe si ce prix
m le directeur sportif et andré
michailof le médecin passeront cette
nuit encore à la prison de foix ils
devront attendre lundi avant d'être
transférée à arras pour être entendue
par le magistrat chargé de la faire nous
évoquions hier un prolongement de la
sphère des dopages à poitiers ou des
flacons de p&o avaient été volés au
centre hospitalier notre confrère france
soir avait mis en cause le coureur
pascal hervé de l'équipe festina il
répond aujourd'hui à cette accusation et
revient sur ses déclarations aux
policiers de lyon qui vous le savez on
entendu l'équipe festina alban nicosie
sur le plan sportif le tour de pascal
hervé s'est arrêté dans ce petit
restaurant de corrèze où les festina
avait annoncé leur retrait sur le plan
judiciaire il en va tout autrement les
coureurs de cette équipe ont été
entendus pendant 48 heures à lyon pascal
hervé donne ce soir sa version par les
eaux aux inspecteurs qui m'ont interrogé
pendant deux jours et moi comment ils
chargeaient reconnu permet de doper j'ai
reconnu seulement d'avoir fait confiance
à un médecin est le seul truc qu'on peut
me reprocher c'est d'avoir accordé ma
confiance à quelqu'un qui n'en étaient
pas forcément honnête
pascal hervé fait allusion aux doses de
paix ont retrouvé dans un véhicule
festina et qui ont valu au directeur
sportif bruno roussel et au médecin eric
hart d'être mis en examen
les enquêteurs veulent désormais savoir
si ces doses ne proviennent pas du
centre hospitalier de poitiers ici cent
trente flacons
celui ci ont été dérobés en février puis
en juin il s'agit des prêts kz1
médicaments qui contient d'importantes
quantités de paix où le produit
incriminé dans les affaires de dopage va
aller très vite dans la sphère potier
surtout pour que je sois complètement
mis hors de cause et avec mon honnêteté
soins sont marqués au moins dans le
journal de ma région comme moi mes
voisins comment les voisins ne croyais
pas que je sois je suis je suis un
vulgaire trafiquant de produits
interdits et je suis pas à la tête d'une
organisation de trafic
les enquêteurs vérifient actuellement
les numéros des lots volée pour savoir
s'ils doivent établir un lien entre ces
deux affaires avec nous ce soir en
duplex de carpentras le directeur du
tour jean-marie leblanc bonsoir merci
d'avoir reçoit notre invitation
jean marie leblanc le tour a frôlé hier
la catastrophe la journée a été plus
calme aujourd'hui est ce que la sérénité
est revenue sur la route du tour
la sérénité est revenue calme sur le
plan sportif non puisque nous avons une
étape extrêmement rapide extrêmement
animée comme celle de la veille
d'ailleurs on se souvient que laurent
jalabert avait tenté une sorte de baroud
d'honneur
l'étape d'aujourd'hui a été animé je
crois que tout a retrouvé ses couleurs
son public sa tradition son ambiance et
ça nous réjouit bien sûr au lendemain
d'une étape difficile je vous le concède
squad un départ d'étape difficile où
effectivement les coureurs ont manifesté
une certaine manière leur ras-le-bol
devant la pression qui était mise sous
sur eux de manière continue depuis le
départ de dublin en raison de cette
affaire de dopage et d'une certaine
manière nous avons pu comprendre que le
couvercle du chaudron d'une certaine
manière expose les coureurs réclame est
un peu de considération et je crois que
la visite du vice-président d'une
cycliste internationale daniel balles ce
matin le fait qu'ils les ai écoutés
qu'il et dialoguer va contribuer pour
beaucoup au retour comme vous le dites
de la sérénité et au retour du sport en
première ligne de ce tour de france est
vraiment eu peur hier que le tour
s'arrête
nous avons eu peur effectivement que
l'étape soit
annulée puisque il a fallu deux heures
de dialogues d'arguments pour expliquer
aux coureurs que l'intérêt général de
même du tour de france du cyclisme était
que l'état puisse disputer et je suis
heureux que la raison ait fini par
l'emporter
alors oui nous aurons eu nous avons eu
quelques craintes en effet mais mais
heureux tout de même de constater que la
raison le bon sens le sport est emporté
sur toute autre considération il
n'empêche que les problèmes de dopage
existe la justice suit son cours est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à revoir tout le
système actuel des contrôles antidopage
vous savez que le système des contrôles
anti dopage n'est pas le fait des
organisateurs de courses cyclistes
quel qu'il soit il est le fait de
l'union cycliste internationale qui
établit des règlements qui établit une
liste de produits interdits qui est à
vis des procédures et nous autres
organisateurs ne faisons que
qu'appliquer le mieux possible le plus
vite possible dans les meilleurs délais
ces procédures ce que nous faisons
depuis dix ans alors si demain les
listes change des procédures change si
les contrôles sont plus fiables car on
le dit qu'ils sont peu fiables
si les scientifiques ceux qui ont la
connaissance du problème nous explique
comment il faut faire pour aboutir à des
contrôles plus fiables
naturellement nous allons nous
appliquerons de la même manière et si
cela peut aboutir l'éradication totale
du du du dopage sont les premiers avis
naturellement s'il est avéré que les
couleurs et les coureurs de tvm se sont
effectivement au ps qu'ils seront exclus
du tour comme l'ont été ceux de festina
bien entendu nous ne pouvons pas avoir
deux manières d'agir ou deux manières de
penser et nous appliquerons en la
circonstance la même ligne de conduite
que nous avons appliqué pour l'équipe
festina à savoir que s'il est avéré que
des faits nouveaux grave atteste que
l'équipe l'équipe tv m a frauduleusement
à tricher avec les règles de l'éthique
de la morale de la compétition sportive
château et france ou s'il y a des aveux
alors nous prendrons la même décision
que nous avons prise avec l'équipe
festina
mais si nous n'avons pas ces éléments
nous n'agirons pas dans la précipitation
jean marie leblanc merci nous changeons
complètement dessus sujet avec une
affaire d'euthanasie à mantes la jolie
dans les
line une infirmière de 28 ans est
soupçonné d'avoir aidé à mourir une
trentaine de patients âgés de son
service elle a reconnu les faits et elle
a été mise en examen pour homicide
volontaire reportage eric bestiaux
mathieu deux régions l'hôpital françois
quesnay de mantes-la-jolie employés la
jeune infirmière depuis trois ans
la justice lui reproche d'avoir aidé à
mourir d'une trentaine de personnes
âgées de 72 à 88 ans ils étaient tous
atteints de cancer en phase terminale
selon la police judiciaire elle agissait
la demande des malades ou des familles
mais elle aurait aussi agi de sa propre
initiative
la direction de l'hôpital a déclaré
avoir reçu des coups de téléphone de
soutien à l'infirmière
mais ici on est avant tout choqué ça
d'abord être un drame pour le service
concerné le personnel a été choqué par
ce qui s'est passé partagés entre le
sentiment d'incrédulité de culpabilité
la jeune femme de 28 ans était bien noté
au sein du service de pneumologie
c'est son comportement étrange qui a
éveillé les soupçons de ses collègues
elle avait présenté semble-t-il car on
n'était pas là une certaine nervosité et
c'est elle qui a fait état du décès d'un
patient donc savez semble étrange alors
que façon générale l'amour
enfin doit être affrontée avec sérénité
pour pouvoir épauler toute la famille
qu'accompagne man après la découverte de
ces agissements au mois de mai par
l'hôpital
l'infirmière aurait fait une tentative
de suicide mise en examen pour homicide
volontaire elle est aujourd'hui libre
aucune famille n'a porté plainte contre
elle elle n'aurait pas agi pour l'argent
mais plutôt parce qu'elle ne supportait
pas de voir souffrir les malades bien au
delà d'un fait divers cette affaire
relance un débat difficile au sein de la
société française
faut-il ou non autoriser l'euthanasie
notamment lorsque des malades en phase
finale de maladies n'ont plus aucun
espoir de survie à cette question le
code pénal ne répond pas le terme d'
euthanasie n'y est pas mentionné une
affaire tragique qui pose une nouvelle
fois la grave question morale de
l'euthanasie au delà les problèmes posés
par la fin de vie bernard kouchner
bonsoir déjà première question comment
réagissez vous à cette affaire de mantes
la jolie
je réagis avec tristesse avec sérieux
mais avec compassion je pense que c'est
un drame que nous pouvons chacun d'entre
nous affronter que nous avons affrontée
chacun d'entre nous je ne voudrais pas
que se rajoute un autre drame à ce que
les familles ont vécu je pense à eux je
sais qu'il y à une loi je suis
responsable de la santé publique je dois
faire appliquer la loi mais il ya aussi
la manière de considérer que la fin de
vie dans notre pays
ce passage n'est pas un épisode assez
médicalisé assez parlé entre nous assez
pris au sérieux que nous avons un retard
considérable
je pense aussi pensant aux familles à
cette jeune femme je ne veux pas me
prononcer sur la sphère je note
qu'aucune famille n'a porté plainte
c'est très important je souhaite que les
pression ne s'exerce pas sur les
familles pour qu un peu tardivement il
porte plainte
alors on le sait l'euthanasie est
illégale en france d'ailleurs je crois
que le conseil des médecins le conseil
de l'ordre estime qu'on ne peut pas
légiférer sur la mort et c'est à dire
qu'on peut pas débattre de ces questions
et monsieur l'euthanasie c'est toujours
un échec de ce qu'il convient
ray de mettre en place tout le temps
c'est à dire l'accompagnement les soins
palliatifs on appelle ça moi j'ai essayé
avec martine aubry nous avons mis en
place des équipes mobiles dans chaque
hôpital sais pas s'il y en avait là en
tout cas pas suffisamment l'euthanasie
de cette manière mettre fin à une vie en
souffrance d'abord je n'aime pas que ce
mot meurtre soit employé n'est ce pas
mais c'est pas moi qui légifèrent je ne
veux pas me prononcer mais mettre fin
aux souffrances en un acte individuel
c'est toujours un échec de
l'accompagnement qui doit être collectif
le fait d'une équipe il faut vous savez
il ya une tradition médicale à mon avis
bien dépasser pour les médecins souvent
la mort est un échec
mais la mort c'est la fin de ma vie de
celle des gens que l'on connaît et il
faut la préparer ce passage doit être
accompagnée médicalement le mieux
possible nous avons vingt ans de retard
là dessus il ya des pays comme le
danemark la hollande l'angleterre
l'allemagne l'australie qui ont légiféré
qui ont justement est-ce qu'il faut
aussi en france et j'y ferrer que
comment traiter cette question
uniquement par le d pour le moment les
jours il faut un débat oui mais il faut
lui parler de ces choses bien sûr
sûrement mais d'abord en en parlant
et puis vous avez je crois qu'il faut
vraiment que ce soit une réponse
d'equipe il faut pas que ce soit un
geste qui entraîne culpabilité et faut
pas que ce soit un geste seul c'est
impossible il faut en parler avec la
famille faut en parler avec l'équipe et
puis il ya une façon d'aider à ce
passage qui nous attend tous
c'est une façon d'atténuer la douleur de
l'accompagner de parler d'être autour
alors l'euthanasie ne se posera plus
mais nous n'en sommes pas là ménard
cauchemar je remercie ce débat autour de
la fin de vie il existe bien évidemment
dans les hôpitaux alors jusqu'où
maintenir la vie ou comment cela
chargement thérapeutique comment
respecter la dignité de la personne dans
ses derniers instants
stéphane guay et frédéric bonnet se sont
rendus dans un établissement hospitalier
d'ici là vu sur notre dame est
imprenable mais les fenêtres de ce
service de l'hôtel dieu reste toujours
closes conditions d'hygiène draconiennes
ici l'on soigne une maladie dont le nom
fait peur la leucémie les soins peuvent
durer des années
ils sont parfois aussi agressif
le mas lui même régulièrement l'équipe
de ce service d'hématologie doit
répondre à la plus difficile des
questions continuer de se battre ou
accepter la mort
ce patient avec la maladie qui l'a jeu
son espérance de vie est d'environ trois
mois plus ou moins deux fois je veux
dire c'est toujours très grossier comme
l'approximation et c'est de cet ordre là
que deuxièmement il est un crack
les seules chances de guérison sur un
crâne de moelle que nous nous refusons à
faire lui sont lâches et vue sur l'état
général parce que là le risque de
mortalité induite par ce traitement
sereine plus de 50 % de mortalité due à
un traitement
nous n'acceptons car en france seul le
médecin prend la responsabilité
d'arrêter le traitement
l'incertitude omniprésente on la
décision délicate
c'est pourquoi toute l'équipe soignante
et consulté le patient bien souvent
inconscient c'est à sa famille de donner
son accord accepté de laisser mourir sa
fille après 10 ans de lutte
cette mère a fait ce choix insupportable
peut-être le seul pour retrouver la
sérénité jusqu'à ce qu'elle attendait la
ville je savais qu'elle voulait vivre
certaines membres certains d'en vivre
mais vivre c'est obligatoirement être en
vie c'est différent donc 6 avec une
mutilation énorme ce qu'elle leur est
acceptée elle non sa tête ça il fallait
que qu'elles appartiennent à la médecine
il fallait qu'elle s'appartiennent à
elle qu'on la respecte et peut-être que
je porte quel ray appartiennent à sa
famille c'est peut-être un peu ça
comment être sûr que l'on a fait le bon
choix cette question toute l'équipe
soignante cela pose encore une fois
après la mort d'une patiente dû à
l'arrêt des traitements au sein de ce
groupe de parole infirmière médecin un
aide-soignant expriment leurs doutes
certains bien sûr aurais tu aimé
continuer à se battre la foire ce qu'on
fait et la croyance dur comme fer à la
métier salvatrice est très ancrée quand
on commence même si ici on apprend
accompagné d'une autre manière les gens
c'est toujours extrêmement frustrant de
dire qu'on est en échec et que nous ce
qu'on apprend en médecine c'est c'est le
traitement au curateur c'est pas c'est
pas on s'arrête un moment et vous
prendre du recul et lentilles on a perdu
à l'apéritif lâcher prise lâcher prise
et ne plus rien faire
certains médecins impuissants aurait
tendance à en rester là
pourtant c'est justement à ce moment
qu'entre en jeu d'autres soins pour
traiter la douleur physique grâce
notamment à des doses de morphine pour
traiter la détresse des familles en
préservant la qualité la dignité des
derniers instants de vie
la tentation est grande d'accélérer de
se dire que ce temps qui reste est un
temps vide qui ne sert à rien et encore
une fois d'utiliser une autre technique
qui consiste tout simplement à plonger
le patient dans l'inconscience et a
accéléré son décès ça ce sont des
pratiques que nous récusons car nous
disons que ce temps qui reste entre
l'art et de la réanimation et le décès
n'est pas forcément un temps vide
c'est au contraire un temps qui peut
être très important pour le patient qui
peut être très important pour sa famille
dans une ultime relation ou vont
s'échanger entre autres
des adieux derniers instants d'une
extrême importance pour la famille qui
trop souvent se heurte encore à une
médecine de techniciens pas toujours
formés aux soins palliatifs est
incapable de lui apporter l'écoutent
dont elle a besoin
c'est un professionnel
le deuil de se dire que son enfant va
mourir que quelqu'un qu'on aime pas
mourir c'est quand même un autre deuil
il faut le respecter celui là elles
seront commence déjà vers le produit et
son moulin
le naufrage de perros guirec que l'abbé
cottard prêtres traditionalistes et
responsable du camp scout a été mis en
examen et incarcéré pour je cite
homicides et blessures involontaires par
manquement délibéré à une obligation de
sécurité et de prudence son avocat
évoque un tragique concours de
circonstances le naufrage a fait je vous
le rappelle cinq victimes quatre scouts
d un plaisancier olivier soussy michel
hiver sous les flashs des photographes
l'abbé jean yves costard quitte le
palais de justice de guingamp pour la
maison d'arrêt de saint brieuc
il y a passé sa première nuit en prison
mise en examen pour homicide
involontaire par manquement délibéré à
une obligation de sécurité
car pour les enquêteurs la mort de
quatre jeunes scouts théoriquement
placés sous sa responsabilité est partie
seule en mer avec trois de leurs
camarades sur un petit dériveur alors
que le vent soufflait n'a rien à voir
avec la fatalité
je considère pour ma part je dirais
qu'il y a dans ce dossier peu de place
au hasard
beaucoup de place où l'accumulation de
fautes graves ce que l'on sait qu'il y
avait au moins finir est donc un
équipier le trou et le problème
essentiel crucial qui me semblent avoir
je dirais un rôle causal extrêmement
fort de l'absence d'éléments compétents
tout simplement de compétent dans le
navire l' enquête préliminaire a mise en
lumière les activités de cette nébuleuse
d'associations de jeunesse proche des
milieux intégristes ou l'entraînement
est quasi militaire
pourtant ce soir les familles des
victimes réaffirment leur soutien à
l'abbé cottard
je suis blessé dans ma chair parce que
j'ai perdu un fils
je suis blessée parce que j'ai appris
que monsieur l'abbé cottard a été
incarcéré comme un brigand comme un
malfaiteur
je demande au juge d'instruction de
reposer sa décision monsieur l'abbé
cottard n'a rien à faire en prison
c'est maintenant à la juge d'instruction
de déterminer les responsabilités
exactes
elle devra aussi vérifier les
témoignages des trois jeunes rescapés
qui affirme que plusieurs bateaux à
moteur sont passés à proximité de leur
embarcation chavirée sans s'arrêter
alors qu'il venait de lancer une fusée
de détresse la disparition d'un ténor du
barreau maître henri rené gareau
l'avocat de christine villemin de simone
weber et des agresseurs de malik
oussékine est décédé d'une crise
cardiaque à 72 ans il est prêt le
cofondateur de l'association légitime
défense qui prône le rétablissement de
la peine de me perquisition hier au
siège de l'idf paris perquisition dans
le cadre d'une enquête sur un mouvement
financier de 5 millions de francs au
profit de l'ancien parti républicain les
sondages flambe toujours pour le
président de la république et le premier
ministre un bond de 11 points pour
jacques chirac et de sept points pour
lionel jospin qui se retrouvent tous les
deux avec 59% d'opinions favorables
selon le sondage ifop du journal du
dimanche
fusillade au capitole à washington un
homme a ouvert le feu dans le célèbre
bâtiment qui abrite le sénat et la
chambre des représentants il a tué deux
policiers et grièvement blessé une
touriste provoquant la panique des
visiteurs à washington philippe gassot
ce matin le drapeau est en berne sur le
capitole et les images de terreur sont
encore sur toutes les télévisions
américaines
aujourd'hui on en sait un peu plus sur
l'homme qui a tiré et tué deux policiers
dans le bâtiment du congrès il vit dans
le montana dans cette cabane exactement
qui ressemble à celle qu'occupait yuna
bamber l'assassin au colis piégé qui a
été condamné à la prison à vie
russell watson c'est le nom du tireur se
croyait persécutés espionné par le
pouvoir
actuellement après 4 heures d'opération
dans la nuit l'assassin présumé
mais est dans un état stationnaire ainsi
qu'une touriste elle aussi grièvement
blessé le président américain s'est
déclarée profondément perturbée
fusillade qui a eu lieu dans le capitole
est un acte de barbarie commis à la
porte principale de la civilisation
américaine à travers tout le pays on
rend hommage aux hommes qui ont laissé
leur vie pour protéger le congrès ce
matin les touristes sont revenus pour la
visite afin de marquer leur attachement
aux institutions mais le coeur y était
pas vraiment les américains ont beaucoup
de mal à admettre que le capitole où se
construit le destin de la nation ait pu
être le théâtre d'un véritable règlement
de comptes contre la démocratie
de nouvelles inondations en chine des
pluies torrentielles se sont abattues
depuis le début de la semaine sur
plusieurs régions et notamment a vu anne
au centre du pays
total le bilan officiel atteint plus de
11 sont victimes ces trois derniers mois
les cambodgiens devant les urnes le
parti au pouvoir affronter les
royalistes du prince norodom ranariddh
mais surtout pour la première fois les
khmers rouges participeront au scrutin
jean-marc il use et dominique merlin ont
pu se rendre dans le bastion semi
autonome de l'ancienne rébellion ils ont
rencontré ieng sary bras droit de
l'ancien dictateur polpot dans le régime
vont donner fit près de deux millions de
morts dans les années 70 un reportage
exclusif passé ces montagnes du
nord-ouest cambodgien il ne faut que
quelques heures de piste pour rejoindre
le bastion de l'ex rébellion mer rouge
sur cette route les armes se sont tues
voilà deux ans mais le déminage continue
une barrière bien dérisoires les
uniformes tout neuf de l'armée
gouvernementale
regardez bien ici les regards changent
ici commence le bon numéro
bienvenue à paris lille palin ex
sous-préfecture de la terreur point de
passage obligé de tous les trafics avec
la thaïlande et trésor de guerre des
khmers rouges
le sous sol de leur fief abondant
pierres précieuses
saphir et rubis sont les meilleurs
alliés des khmers rouges 100 millions de
dollars rejoignent chaque année les
coffres des banques thaïlande org
ces réfugiés nous récolterons que des
miettes éternels perdants dans la guerre
comme dans la sphère
non elle n'a jamais rien trouvé mais au
moins ici on la nourrit
et puis un jour que ses enfants ont du
travail à palin
ben ali n'a rouges dont les toitures
parle désormais dollars palin qui
s'engraissent chaque jour un peu plus
sur la paix avec son premier magasin
hors taxe et son casino qui ouvrira
après les élections le commerce n'est
plus une abomination et la vente des
rubis n'est plus réservé aux parties
j'achète je vends des pierres et je fais
un que deux des fils depuis le
ralliement de notre région c'est calme
on n'a plus les problèmes d'avant cette
marchande à surmonter sa peur des khmers
rouges pour rejoindre sa fille ici je
peux lui dédie ma vie dit elle autant du
génocide khmer rouge
l'argent était proscrit les montres même
devait disparaître
aujourd'hui les khmers rouges se sont
reconvertis en commerçant en politicien
ou en à fieux et les gens ne parlent ils
veulent fois coop eu d'élection et
beaucoup de dollars sont encore la
meilleure recette pour leur avenir un
avenir confie à cet homme de 47 ans
ritchen gouverneur de palin et symbole
de la nouvelle génération numéro la
majorité des cambodgiens ne veut plus
faire la guerre moi même qui a rang de
commandant des khmers rouges
j'ai personnellement organisé le
ralliement au gouvernement de phnom penh
des neuf régions du point un ralliement
spectaculaire décidé en 96 par le bras
droit du 8 l'air cambodgien ieng sary
qui coule aujourd'hui une retraite
paisible à payet
aujourd'hui nous arriver
je oui c'est bien lui le lien qui
seraient plutôt de polpot vous dites que
cette période a été une période noire
pour le pour le pays oui aux histoires
partenaire et vous étiez ministre et
vous ne saviez pas je ne connais pas
même le directeur de la ferté milon
premiers pas ne connaît que trop comment
conduire vérité et on ne me fera pas et
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous seriez prêt à
passer devant un tribunal international
la yam beaucoup la compression et
n'avait ce ne peut pas dépenser
aujourd'hui le compagnon de route des
bourreaux du cambodge a même fondé un
nouveau parti démocratique
mais dans les rues de paille l'insee
partisans ferons campagne pour leur
ancien ennemi mortel
le premier ministre uhuru scène étrange
royaume à la mémoire confisqué le
cambodge auront encore longtemps besoin
des gardiens du temple pour conjurer ses
démons à la sport et football je la
prends un instant des adjoints pour
roger lemerre roger lemerre qui
succédera au poste de sélectionneur
national de l'équipe de france de
football championne du monde sera
assisté par les entraîneurs guy stéphan
qui naguère père et à lyon et à bordeaux
et par rené girard l'ancien entraîneur
de strasbourg
tennis l'équipe de france féminine
rencontre la suisse en demi finale de la
coupe de la fédération yannick noah
alors capitaine a fait confiance à une
revenant julia l'aria une novice amélie
mauresmo
le résultat n'est pas encore très
concluants cédric beaudou ne vous y
trompez pas ces petites filles suisse et
leur joli sourire non rien d'inoffensif
bien au contraire
pour cette demi finale de la coupe de la
fédération en effet l'équipe de france
féminine tenante du titre ne part pas
favorite
yannick noah l'entraîneur français on
est conscient et pour pallier l'absence
de mary pierce et de sandrine testud
il choisit julie halard pour affronter
martina hingis
la numéro un mondiale 25 matches en fed
cup et seulement 3 défaites
le pari est audacieux mais dans le
premier set julie halard mais la
suissesse en difficulté à 3 jeux partout
la française s'offre même le luxe de
prendre le service de martina hingis
allard mène alors 4 jeux à 3 mais devant
son public
hingis égalise au jeu suivant pour
s'imposer dans la première manche 7 jeux
à 5
le deuxième set est une formalité pour
martina hingis qui offre le premier
point la suisse sur le score de 7-5 6-1
puis c'est au tour d'amélie mauresmo de
défendre les chances françaises
après avoir concédé de justesse le
premier set à patty schnyder 7 5
la jeune française fait honneur à sa 1re
sélection en fed cup elle remporte en
effet la deuxième manche 6 jeux à 2 à
deux reprises dans le troisième set la
française prend le service de son
adversaire mais systématiquement patty
schnyder égalise pour l'emporter
finalement 7 5 2 6 6 3 j'ai vraiment un
sentiment qu amélie peut gagner en deux
sets
elle a énormément énormément d'occasions
et mais elle a des passages à vide
demain melli mauresmo rencontre martina
hingis en cas de passage à vide
la france serait éliminée de la fed cup
verdun lieu de souvenir et symbole de la
réconciliation un spectacle son et
lumière avec 300 figurants français et
allemands retrace la terrible bataille
qui avait fait en 1916 300000 morts et
450 mille blessés verdun où est implanté
aujourd'hui le centre mondial de la paix
gérard dalmaz pascal piot 300000 tué
quatre cent cinquante mille blessés
la grande bataille de la grande guerre
verdun 1916 1998 berlin ne veut plus
être que la ville de la réconciliation
l'association connaissance de la meuse
réalise un spectacle poignant sur
l'enfer devenu espérances
la preuve l'international des 300
figurants exemple pour le rôle du curé
français un allemand né en prusse
orientale
je ne pourrais peut-être pas facilement
acceptée jusqu'où revanche alors comme
j'ai senti pour la paix et que chaque
minute passée 6 août 14
la moisson des blés d'or s'interrompt
pour la moisson des champs d'horreur le
malheur s'abat également sur les civils
et les réfugiés
les soldats sont bien souvent des gamins
ici et le tombeau de la jeunesse
ce n'est plus qu'une question de jours
pour que cette ville au recueil des
français tombent entre nos mains à
berlin on rêve déjà de la percée de
verdun mais à bertin on ne passe pas
l'acharnement pendant dix mois
la chair se mélange à la terre les verts
les puces les allées corbeau mangent à
leur faim et bris d'égalité
déluge de feu sur la quarantaine de fort
du pourtour de berlin 230 village
quasiment détruit neuf comme une race et
corps et biens à tout jamais
le partage de votre souffrance commune
vous révèle le martyre de cette humanité
obligé de se battre les morts ouvre les
yeux des vies vont désormais la ville
martyre est le symbole mondial de la
réconciliation
qu'il est long le chemin des flammes à
la lumière certains fans en rêvaient
depuis 30 ans le stade de france les
accueille une enceinte à la mesure de
leur légende des rolling stones seront
dans quelques instants sur scène face à
85 mille spectateurs louis carzou et
bruno les verts tous s'y sont rendus dès
cet après midi
demandez le programme quantité limitée
60 francs le programme officiel
à part un programme à moitié prix ou
bien dédicacé par mick jagger lui-même
le plus difficile à trouver au stade de
france c'est tout simplement un petit
coin à l'ombre mais qu'importe ils
étaient déjà plusieurs centaines d midi
à guetter l'ouverture des portes
car pour chacun un concert des rolling
stones c'est forcément un événement
j'ai attendu trente ans devant les voir
non pas parce qu'avant je n'avais pas
les moyens
et il est vrai que ce soir tout est
réuni pour fêter l'événement une sono de
plus de 250 mille boîtes de 800
projecteurs et quelques 85 mille fans
attendus pour le premier concert dans le
stade des champions du monde
de quoi impressionner celui qui aura la
lourde de tâche du lever de rideau jean
louis aubert
mais pour l'instant les tests sont bons
hier à la balance un poney un peu
connaissance des lieux j'ai entendu les
des disques et ça sonnait
merveilleusement bien quand j'ai
l'impression que ce stade est très bien
conçu pour ça
bref selon toute probabilité vers 21h
cette scène ressemblera à ça
et c'est aussi pour ça tout simplement
qu'on aime les rolling stones
inusable rolling stones c'est la fin de
ce journal je vous en rappelle les
principaux titres le tour de france la
course reprend ses droits
coureurs et responsable se retrouveront
en fin de saison pour régler la crise du
dopage
le directeur les médecins des tvm sont
en prison l'euthanasie à l'hôpital de
mantes-la-jolie une infirmière mise en
examen pour homicide volontaire elle est
accusée d'avoir aidé à mourir une
trentaine de malades voilà dans un
instant patrice drevet pour la météo
belle journée de dimanche je vous
retrouve demain soir excellente soirée
sur france 2 au soir
il y a des